to go back to your point about mansion  claiming he doesn't like attention i  mean it's like the guy's writing op-eds  in newspapers regularly to you know a  handful of notable times in this early  presidency of joe biden  talking about why he's not for this and  why this and that and why we need to  compromise for a guy who doesn't like  attention he's taking a lot of meetings  and writing a lot of op-eds that no  one's forcing him to write yep and he  goes on cable news all the time you  could probably argue he has more power  than chuck schumer right i mean like in  some way think about the most powerful  people in washington obviously biden's  going to be at the top of the list you  can come up with some other people as  well but mansion's right up there with  them no doubt about it